hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to horror of the deep now
there's an early access horror game and
I believe it's got an element of random
Wow you throw you get thrown right in
there and I also imagine there's some
horror in the deep that I got to see so
did I fall down this wall or did I
intentionally come down here with no
rope I fell down here this is the
beginning of Batman alright I got more
to fall alright apparently I'm going
deep alrighty then what do we got here
well when you read this you are already
a traitor of your own ancestry oh nice
like me and countless other outcasts
death awaits those who turn back
slaughtering the weak and scared who
dare to crawl back back into a kingdom
they do not belong anymore this is your
world now and down here death is patient
he's gulp king in the darkness reaching
with his gory hands for the last thing
that you can call your own mistakes will
be paid in blood and hesitation will be
your end
Elias but I like to hesitate and look
back a lot it's like my favorite thing
to do so
ah excellent so what about this where am
I going exactly why so I've been outcast
that much I've picked up on with my big
old brain and oh my god that looks
beautiful who built this [ __ ] who built
this outcast sanctuary down here in the
deep why do I always question that I
literally go build this I thought we
were underground wait what the [ __ ]
happened okay it's like everything in
Dark Souls like who built that [ __ ]
about this [ __ ] how far down does it
gooo all right didn't expect come wait
we are watching come to us never alone
anymore die we are waiting for you many
have been sent here to die and many will
follow our fate has been predetermined
by the wrath of the King we are cursed
to slowly rot in this lonely godforsaken
place but is this the end
I have the feeling there might be
another destination for us all follow me
into this forgotten place and I shall be
light in your darkest hour life is why
does he sound like the pastor from out
cast out last outcast you know my
favorite game outcast I do not know I'm
just sending into the deep I thought I
was ro the atrium of renunciation I see
you like big words to me also am talking
big words most time me like to talk and
make me sound smart it real good fun
last time for me going can I take one of
these torches oh hello any prisoners
here oh hey sir how are you doing you
being treated okay
are you a denizen of the deep [ __ ]
god damn [ __ ] you with your statue
[ __ ] you think you can scare me [ __ ]
off I don't like the face on you not
calling you ugly or nothing but I just
saying you're ugly as [ __ ]
alright what else we got here anybody
down here anybody down here wanna mess
with the likes of me Oh moralist
knowledge all this time this forgotten
sanctorium was lying in the darkest vale
of our Lost Ages inside the gloomy halls
a horrific death awaits us but I have
seen a glimmer beyond the madness they
don't know this place any more like we
do now therefore this is the last trial
before our new true destiny I can see it
well thank you Ella v for your insight
oh I don't know if I'm going the right
way but I'm gonna keep plowing ahead
hello Oh God death awaits you I like it
right nothing here is the hesitation
going to kill me now is the turning back
going to make me dead kind of reminds me
of amnesia the Dark Descent
right flying that's how you're gonna be
you're gonna spook me with a gas pipe is
that really how I'm going to be spooked
here well I don't like that very much
Oh a big G a big honking big boy of a
key me liking a big boy honker
well maybe elephants can give me some
insight into why it's so much gas and
where this place even came from but yeah
you can't deny a little bit of amnesia
three keys will lead to your destiny
pathetic okay three three three got it
I've got one of these keys where's the
uppers spider baby what are you doing
Spidey that don't look good I probably
shouldn't step on that if I had to guess
about that that's probably not something
I should step on judging by the dead
body in that spider hey buddy are you
doing spider friend Oh big boy skulls
man everything's big boy in this place
today I woke up to the cracking noise of
something stepping on a branch I was
prepared to stare into the dead eyes of
one of those monsters and waited for my
life to end nothing happened
I rolled cautiously to the other side
and saw a slender man he was bent over
our fallen brothers and sisters and
seemed to be trying to remove their
limbs
I stood up prepared to fight the
intruder the slim man looked at me with
his blood red eyes and disappeared
laughing in the darkness that doesn't
sound like the Slenderman I know you
also seem very dead so what did you know
either
I am gonna live so I am the one who will
find my way no I take it the last key
might be over here somewhere
oh there it is any traps no no don't do
anything right do you then carry on with
your life and hopefully I'll never see
you again I got three keys now auditory
above the crib where's the auditorium of
the Bloods it's probably next door no
game go out there all righty then
where mm go what M me m do you am going
aw [ __ ] who built this Oh Bilbo this who
built all of this who built that who
built that it's the only question that I
got it who built that you I would
hello we are all banished from the
lasting Kingdom by the cruel eager king
from the highlands a man who treasures
his own wealth and power more than
anything a man who uses expelling and
slaughtering in order to keep his
precious fraudulent hopes burning
sadly you could be one of the many
peaceful souls who didn't deserve this
however lamentations will remain on her
to eternity
okay thank you elephants you're very
eloquent elephants I like the way you
speak elephants
you got a good way with the word doing
okay I thought I was in the auditorium
oh this is the forbidden crib then we
get to the forbidden blood it's dark in
here I don't know if I like that cuz
judging by the way Oh help me fear for
the weak please hurry
I've got a feeling sprinting into this
probably bad idea but here we go
our
[ __ ] hell what the [ __ ] I hear that
you heard step steps didn't you I heard
step steps I'm not crazy I'm a little
crazy but I'm not crazy
our know their lands are now rotting
like the rest of the world they cannot
stop their disease they cannot stop the
hate from spreading everything will be
devoured in the end their destiny will
be no better than ours our bones were
molded to dust and our soul will flee
from this world but the time has not yet
come there is hope for us in the deepest
chasm it is said that a group of
outcasts has been able to form a new
civilization deep under the earth
surviving in a place full of unknown
threats of another time and if is okay
thank you
elephants your insight as usual is
always appreciated
I don't like that don't get up please
who are you and why are you there oh
you're crying I like that even less now
all right I have died I have done the
daddy okay quickly answer the short
answer don't go and near anything that
is crying ever if you're ever in a
horror game and something's crying kill
it
just kill it just be proactive all right
let's try that again
yeah I'll help you speed you on into the
afterlife yep he's at Garbo oh I gotta
go in there really I gotta go in there
I'm just got turn and run as soon as it
starts going trust god damnit [ __ ] you
god damn it come on you piece of [ __ ] no
no I'm not even gonna look back I'm not
gonna look back I'm not gonna look back
I swear I'm not gonna look back oh I'm
gonna look back Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
this really does that respawn even feels
like Dark Souls in a weird way god of
Dark Souls you had no weapons trusted
know about it nothing about I think
maybe I can go around it other than that
if I can skirt around it because it's
it's pretty close that you have to get
to it for it to be mad at you I trust
neither of those options I'm gonna go
with this option err well I don't like
that oh I don't like this so why are
there gravestones big-boy key all right
well got that one there more keys than I
need to get around here and why
don't like this at all okay I think this
is gonna go above her maybe yeah in the
second level if I can get some solace oh
don't break oh okay that would have been
a douchey moment to break but I think
we're okay
whoa whoa whoa okay all right okay I
love the coloring on this by the way
just to talk about the game and not
about my own fear for a second
it's like it it's very uh well okay you
guys are dead why Oh alrighty then was
that the only reason that I needed to
come down here for that key there must
have been something else there right
there must have been something else
I can't believe that if there would just
be one key right cuz it can't really go
the nah camera Li go the other way I
might be able to sneak around her
towards the back but there was also
another way down here to the left I got
to remember that and that probably opens
the other door back just in case I need
to bull get out of here yeah it does
okay so I gotta imagine rounder either
gonna die or is gonna pay off I'm
probably gonna die
I don't like you you don't like me I
don't like you you don't leave me you
keep off that rock you don't like me
oh we don't like each other we don't
like each other we don't like each other
very much okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine
Oh somehow we're fine what is that what
is that oh it's a horror of the deep I
know that but what is that no no no no
that's a no no on that oh no no no no no
no no oh there's no other way to go is
there I see that three key door lock
[ __ ] you oh just lost and lost I'm a
babe in the woods is that a key you are
lost north's elephants there was a child
in one of those halls it was crying and
shouting for help no one you meet in
this rotting health shouts for help
why would they there's no one here to
help we decided to leave the child they
would sown destiny and continued our way
in the safe distance a crying child is
loud who would probably have member
death for all of us if it even was a
child Vasily's oh thanks for the advice
after I've already met this crying child
lucky for them that they mistrusted it
I'm still looking for keys finding lure
after you need the lure is always my
favorite
my skinny buddy buddy no no no no no no
there's a dead end all right where's the
goddamn keys keys are know where the
keys are exactly nowhere someone here
please tell me there's one here okey yes
okay just one more to go
oh hello today there was something that
looked like another child it was silent
crawling slowly in our direction
it seemed wounded our leader finally
decided to help the wounded child he was
reaching towards the child as the
monster jumped towards his face and
pierced his throat with his sharp knife
like teeth he was dead before he could
even react may his soul rest in peace
okay so I get it I'm not gonna let those
things touch me
no touches from them to me I understand
full well Suffolk and file I know about
your knife like teeth okay that's
another one Oh freaking dick Oh God
oh no oh wait oh this way I don't like
that okay I didn't like that hello don't
go this way I'm going this way
apparently
oh I'm I regret death I regret this
immensely there's no key in here why did
I go in here
this is not a good way to go there's a
lot of dead bodies
okay well this was a mistake trust me
yeah I didn't trust you before but
probably should have not that way not
that way that was a bad way so I gotta
get around to the left there oh okay
yeah come this way come on no no way
right come come come come come
okay you're slow you're slow you're slow
I'm fine you're slow
let's be enough birth to be able to get
by literally do okay we're good we're
good for good service got it
oh hey Oh we'd see okay no no no no no
no no no
no no no no so there's gotta be one more
around here somewhere I just don't know
where whoa okay oh it was a hole in the
ground but I don't know if that's was
supposed to be there okay so anyway I'm
actually completely out of time
I can't I and I don't even know if this
game is finished because remember this
game is in early access very early
access but what they got going on here
right now very good very very good if
there is more to this game let me know
down in the comments because this is
really really good what they got here so
this has a lot of potential I was
terrified at moments and it really
scared me more when there was nothing
than when there was something cuz I
didn't know what to expect and that's
really good out of game in all honesty
like even the character models you could
tell that they're a little low res but
still it was scary so let me know what
you think thank you everybody so much
for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
[Music]